well well reject nation
looks like andrew garfield is in the
news spitting some bull crap
that's what i say going out there
saying holy hold on
3 i'm just a jewish actor who loves to
play devout christians all the time
i call bs andrew i call bs
you know man yeah you're not really
jewish now
i prove it so i haven't seen this yet i
saw it
circular i saw like quotes circulating
social media
bad batch in a patreon video took up
most of yesterday and
bad batch did all right and i was like i
don't want to film anything else
this is from josh horowitz is he in the
showdown josh horowitz
that's news to me if he is let's see
what andrew garfield
has to say i refuse to concede
that he's not in spider-man 3. don't buy
until i'm in the theaters and wildly
wrong about him not being in spider-man
yes yes
i mean they got katie holmes's on-again
off-again boyfriend
so you know and then if they can get
alfred molina that's what i'm talking
about
then of course
i don't know how to bring up the
spiderman stuff because obviously i
don't even want to like
ruin anything if there is something to
ruin except there isn't anything to ruin
bro
i have to just quickly just cut you off
there's nothing to ruin
really like like it's so crazy like it's
just gotten out of hand this is all
[ __ ] dude it's [ __ ] hilarious to
me because it's like
because i because i do have this twitter
account and i like i see
like how often like spider-man is
trending and it's like people
freaking out about a thing and i'm just
like
guys guys like
i i wish i could just like be able to
speak to everyone and say like
how did this take off because you you
are i recommend that you chill
like listen i can't speak for anything
i've talked to myself sure
like like they might be doing something
but then ain't none like
i ain't got a call so
okay well that makes my life easier okay
let me cut you off before kevin feige
has one of the five snipers in the room
pull the trigger
you know how well-guarded these secrets
are
okay okay no that's good that's
unequivocal you know what it feels like
though
it feels like because this hasn't come
up yet in an interview but like
do you ever play the game werewolf no
or mafia yeah yeah yeah you know that
game
i think it's kind of similar where it's
like you're convincing everyone that
you're not
in the mafia right like i feel like i'm
in a game of [ __ ] werewolf
or mafia where i'm like i'm not the
werewolf
i promise you i am not the werewolf and
everyone's like you're the werewolf
you're the [ __ ] werewolf look at him
he's like he's doing this okay so for
the record my friend on a stack of
whatever you have there
you are not as of this taping in or have
any knowledge of being in
the next spider-man movie just so you
know if you're the werewolf or you're in
the mafia
the whole point is to deny yeah then
you're gonna make that as convincing as
possible to really sell it
terrible metaphor andrew garfield
or maybe he's just giving a clue to all
his true fans who are paying real
attention
he's not outright denying it no
um i don't believe you
you are not as of this taping in or have
any knowledge of being in
the next spider-man movie i feel
like like i feel i feel like i like
haven't i just said that
but you haven't said
you got asked in person listen i would i
would have gotten a call by now that's
all i'm saying
okay um i don't wanna like i don't wanna
rule anything out maybe they want to
call me maybe they're going to call me
like and say like hey people want this
like i don't want to like say they're
testing the waters maybe they're like
yeah they're doing like a market
research thing
just just say no it's a yes or no
question
you have to lie did you see that or yes
or no are you in it
i feel i feel i feel i feel i feel i
feel
i feel like i said that at the end there
especially with the
with the stutters i don't know i got
torn
early on because i was like i could
understand a position where you're in
you're andrew garfield you're a
successful actor you're a public figure
people
get really hyped up about stuff we've
seen this in marvel before
where people are going to take it way
too seriously that's a lot of pressure
to have on you but it it goes on
to such an extent and then by the end it
is kind of so exaggerated
and when he asks him flat out he's like
so you basically saying what we're
saying is
so just say no you're not in it he goes
around about it in a lot of different
again it's like well maybe you didn't
get a call maybe they communicate
with you some other way like there are a
lot of ways that you could poke at this
and i feel like you know he's probably
also
it's a podcast he's got to be having
some fun with us you know
there's a thing called lying by omission
absolute
vodka and i mastered that in network
marketing like 10 years ago okay
and uh not so good at it now he
says as he proceeds that's what you love
that's what somebody who wants me not to
think they're about to sell me on
network marketing
this to me is like lying by omission
because he did not flat out deny it it's
pretty simple kevin feige has had times
where he's even flat out said
no yes you know yeah this
is something where he easily could have
just said that if it is a no he could
have easily just been like
no i'm not in it but i'm open to being
in it if they give me a call i want to
rule anything out that's way more
believable
yes than anything he said i'm holding
strong
i'm holding the line until
this movie is without your theaters
so yeah yeah you're gonna be dedicated
even when the movie's in theaters you're
gonna be like i gotta go back and see if
he was in the background somewhere
there's ways to phrase your words to
really make it seem like you are saying
no
for example i feel like i just said that
i know i
was here give me this question please i
feel like
i said that is not the same thing as
saying no
i'm not in it there's one is a direct
response
and the other is metaphors circling
around yeah i think you had a really
good point is i i almost
feel like he gave us the answer right
there with what you pointed out about
you know bringing up the mafia werewolf
metaphors like it's probably what you're
doing right now
is this you're trying to realize sell
the fact that you're
not in the mafia one really you know you
are the quote i read was i never got the
call that was the quote i saw gotcha
so i was like i didn't see any quotes
going and the second i heard that quote
i was like
that's not it
there's other ways of hashing this out
your agent could have got this
yeah you could have got the call you
talked with your you know i don't know
i don't know all right we'll see we'll
see how it turns out guys do you believe
him what do you prefer hacksaw ridge
or the
[Music]
uh it's um he's a priest an adam driver
yeah and they're
searching for liam neeson and then what
is that
fox fox sent us a couple of gifts in the
mail one was this like great beautiful
silicone mellow sheets beautiful
beautiful it's on the bed right now but
this i have been moving this around to
every single room that i am in this home
here it was in the living room it was
like this is a neck and shoulder
massager i am using it
constantly hit this power button see it
does that sexual right look at that
shiatsu
and then you control the pressure by how
like much
uh pressure you put on in your arms and
it is so
relaxing you can even improvise and move
into like your center back lower back
okay move it anywhere in your body i am
using this
since day one yes it meets you like i've
needed a massage
so bad you don't know how grateful i am
to you for this this is so
it's so like oh my gosh i love you fox
i'm not ever
grateful for this this is incredible you
rock
you're the best i'm gonna do way less
editing these days this is the new
reactions andrew garfield you're full of
crap oh but i am
so relaxed silence was the movie science